the out-of-control migrant crisis at our
border and in many Democrat run cities
across the country is leading to some
bad blood between Democrat
leaders President Biden and New York
city mayor Eric Adams now have
reportedly not spoken in almost a year
as the Big Apple here gets flooded by
illegal immigrants now Adams recently
had to announce some major budget cuts
to education and police and other parts
of the city budget in order to pay for
illegal migrants now he's repeatedly
blasted Joe Biden for not doing enough
to help City address the
influx the national government must do
their share this is a national problem
it's not a New York City problem Chicago
problem Massachusetts problem the
national government should be picking up
this tab and it should not be coming out
of the backs of everyday New
Yorkers th this is so obviously a
dereliction of Duty uh by the president
the vice president uh the the entire
Biden Administration uh Jimmy you're
you're a true blue New York as I was
looking at these comments and and the
mayor's um
statements what's the word on the street
how do people feel here knowing that
these things are essential services are
being cut they are this is I consider
this clown on clown crime and I'll
explain okay clown one obviously Biden
he turned the southern border into what
the college bar that doesn't check ID
once the word gets out that anyone can
get in everybody comes and what's
happening un likee the college bar is
the people coming aren't paying for
their alcohol the bill is getting passed
on to people like clown number two Eric
Adams who declared himself a sanctuary
City back when meant doing so meant
nothing okay being a sanctuary city
under Trump was good branding because no
human beings the legal but no human
beings were coming so you never had to
actually step up and own your behavior
now they're actually coming because of
Biden so I consider it clown on clown
because Adams was posturing to begin
with and Biden is just you know
abandoned any pretense of caring about
our country first that's absolutely true
and Nicole to that point about you know
we heard a lot of people especially in
the last election talking about uh you
know there is no illegal human and we
should have essentially open borders and
everyone is welcome in the United States
of America but now we're seeing
different people kind of change their
tune when they're feeling the impacts on
their communities well that's right and
elections and words they have
consequences and now we're finally
starting to see the consequences of some
of those policies you know mayor Adams
has found himself stuck stuck in this
dichotomy that really he has created
over 140,000 migrants have come to the
city since last year and all of a sudden
the city's resources are depleted and so
he's starting to scramble but while he's
doing a little bit he's still not doing
enough so he is starting to push back on
the right to shelter law that that's
been in place since 1989 where if you're
homeless this city has to provide you
housing if you ask for it and now
they're finding not just you know
American homeless but also these
migrants coming in they have a right to
shelter as well so mayor Adams is
actually trying to push back on that
little bit that hasn't gone through but
yet at the same time earlier this year
there's a homeless Bill of Rights that
was actually passed and the mayor didn't
veto it he just said he signed it and
said okay and that Bill of Rights
essentially makes it legal to just sleep
on the street which is why you can
continue to see migrants and more
homeless on the street and so and he
keeps the sanctuary City status so until
you make it illegal to be illegal we're
going to have ourselves in this
situation and it's not just innocent
migrants that are coming in we already
know that are people on the terror watch
list there are so many Goda ways this is
extremely dangerous to our local
communities and our country as a whole
and and those threats Joey um to our
security I mean essentially when we
don't have borders we don't have a
country we don't we certainly don't have
a secure country and we're learning more
and more about how these are not all
just people fleeing their home countries
for a better life no yeah I know this
issue pretty well from one perspective I
grew up in a town that is now 78 to 90%
Hispanic depending on what if it's city
limits or where you are what school
you're looking at uh mostly Mexican
migrants now mostly second and third
generation Americans of of descendants
of Mexicans who came here illegally to
work because it's a big textile industry
so I grew up these are best friends
people I went to school with for 13
years people I know really well and are
proud Americans that's the difference in
what's happening today and what happened
in towns like mine for 20 years but
here's the deal it's not mostly Mexican
migrants coming it's migrants coming
from all over countries that aren't just
South and Central America uh people
coming from China people come from Iran
uh from Afghanistan from Saudi Arabia
from different places are being caught
at the border we don't know why they're
there and here's the deal we have a stat
that shows that a lot more people on the
terror watch list are coming from the
northern border than the southern border
but I think what that doesn't take into
account is the amount of traffic coming
through the southern border that no one
knows about we use this term guideways
how do we know right how do we know
right and and Katie as we see the impact
on these Social Services in cities
across the country is we see the impacts
on where our taxpayer dollars are going
uh we're seeing the reality of of the
the national security threat that we're
facing and yet there is no message
coming from the administration saying if
you come here you will be sent away
there is no real use of the ever verify
program to to limit those coming here
seeking employment H how do you think
this impacts uh us as a country as we
head in this next election well there's
no movement from President Joe Biden to
actually use his executive Authority as
president Trump did to stop this problem
because they are so
afraid because of their political base
of going back to those policies that
worked because it simply had the word
Trump in it it's been detrimental to the
country Eric Adams is you know he was is
he was talking about New Yorkers having
to pay the bill for this and he said
that he wants the federal government to
take on the bill I'm from Arizona all
these people in New York City and
Washington DC and Philadelphia we're
fine when this problem was only in
border states and in small towns when
the burden of resource management was
put on taxpayers there but when it comes
to their city after they decided they
were going to be a sanctuary City in
virtue signal and reality has hit them
in the face and now they're dealing with
the fact they have to cut Social
Services and they can't just raise taxes
into Oblivion to pay for all of this
they now want all taxpayers to pick up
the bill notice he didn't say stop it at
the border he's also blamed uh Greg
Abbott the governor of Texas for this
problem he has not held Joe Biden
accountable for any of this they haven't
had a serious conversation as we now
know they aren't talking about actually
issuing some kind of deterrence when it
comes to this problem and no one wants
to admit that it is a resource
management issue if you have too many
people in a place not everybody can have
that what's available and I've been
talking to a couple of Republicans who
actually in the Republican GOP in
Manhattan and they are actually pretty
confident that they can flip some seats
or at least get close as a result of
this issue alone so people vote for this
and they have a choice and policies
changed based on people who are in
charge and they so to watch that
according to coper there's Mexico has
more than 1 million job openings
Nationwide it seems like that remain in
Mexico law may have been good for people
seeking jobs hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else